das impfstoff desaster in deutschland
ist nur noch eine katastrophe und
gleichzeitig sind die schulen dicht
was läuft schief in unserem land wenn
wir sehen dass in israel zum beispiel
schon über 30 prozent der menschen
geimpft sind
was läuft schief in unserem land wenn
die altenheime so katastrophal da stehen
so ungeschützt das jeden tag alte
menschen sterben müssen und was läuft
schief in unserem land dass die jüngsten
nicht mehr unterrichtet werden und über
dieses thema möchte ich mit meinen
gästen der bundesbildungsministerin anja
karliczek dem fdp chef christian lindner
und dem spd gesundheitsexperten karl
lauterbach sprechen schönen guten abend
guten abend an diesem wochenende haben
wir getitelt dieses wochenende bricht
uns das herz es ging um die alten die
sterben müssen auch deshalb weil es
nicht genügend impfstoff liegt ich bin
jetzt verbunden mit jemandem der an
diesem wochenende tatsächlich das herz
gebrochen wurde
sie ist korrespondentin in israel für
die welt christine kensche und ihre
großmutter ist an diesem wochenende in
deutschland mit corona gestorben während
in israel um sie herum die jungen
menschen geimpft werden während sogar
kinder schon geimpft werden gab es für
ihre großmutter in deutschland noch
keinen impfstoff und das macht sie
wütend frau kennt
wie geht es ihnen nach diesem wochenende
zunächst einmal mein herzliches beileid
für den verlust ihrer großmutter wie
wütend sind sie ja ist jetzt keine
journalistische kategorie eigentlich
aber da ich selber betroffen bin ergab
ich bin also hier stellen sich einfach
zwei fragen meine großmutter 92 das eine
sie noch nicht geimpft war und wie kann
es sein dass sie sich im
ein haus mit 19 ansteckt also da ist
ganz offensichtlich was er falsch
gelaufen und in diesem krassen kontrast
was ich ihnen israel erlebe wenn ich das
einfach unfassbar was ich für
nachrichten aus solch natur und leser
auch von kollegen und freunden die alte
eltern oder großeltern haben frau kenne
die bundeskanzlerin hat zum coroner tod
alter menschen in heime diese woche auch
gesagt es bricht mir das herz
ist das ein trost für sie ja das ist
jetzt kein trost für mich es geht mir
jetzt auch nicht darum direkt die
kanzlerin anzuklagen aber ist das ja
eine ganz einfache frage die eine sache
ist das noch nicht genug impfstoff hat
das sind komplexer sachverhalt da will
ich mit sich eines konkret beurteilen zu
können
die andere sache ist warum man dem stoff
den man hat nicht effektiv verteilt
bekommt und ich erlebe dass hier in
impfzentren war ich habe mit menschen
gesprochen werden dann alte leute ja am
kz überlebende zuteil
die werden dann teilweise persönlich
angerufen und her gebeten
zum impfen und das geht innerhalb von
zehn minuten dann ließ sich irgendwie
aus deutschland oder höre dass die 89
jährige mutter eines bekannten in
brandenburg selber aus den nachrichten
aus dem radio in liegen muss das jetzt
dran ist dann hotline anrufen soll wie
sie tagelang mich erreicht und dann gibt
es in ganz brandenburg zwei impfzentren
die weit weg sind wir alle wissen wie
gut die infrastruktur brandburg ist wie
soll die neuen aktien jeder hinkommen
also dass in alise sachen die machen
mich fassungslos von mir aus könnte noch
mal ganz kurz die werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich in dieser woche geimpft
in israel ist die impfquote über 30
prozent selbst kinder werden bereits
geimpft in israel
wenn sie jetzt den fall ihrer großmutter
sehen glauben sie in israel würde sie
noch leben
gut es ich bin kein arzt ich kann das
nicht beurteilen wo ragen sie
letztendlich gestorben ist aber ich
hätte auf jeden fall sehr viel bessere
chancen gehabt noch zu leben ja sie hat
im krankenhaus eine lungenentzündung
entwickelt eben durch
durch die chronische erkrankung und vor
allem während meiner großmutter erspart
geblieben in ihren letzten tagen noch
auf eine corona station verlegt so sehr
wie wo alles in plastik gewickelt ist
meine verwandten hätten sie besuchen
können hätten sich verabschieden können
und mich nur mein vater in plastik
verpackt mit plastik kann schon hätte
noch einmal ihre hand halten können
meist schon fast zu spät war
also das wäre ihr sicherlich erspar
gewesen wenn sie nicht noch am leben
pokale check sie haben von dem fall
gehört was vor kämpfe berichtet hat über
ihre großmutter während um sie herum in
israel die menschen geimpft werden sie
selbst ein impfangebot bekommt ist ihre
großmutter mit corona in deutschland
gestorben hat die bundesregierung eine
mitschuld daran dass die großmutter von
frau kensche tot ist also erstmal auch
von meiner seite ein herzliches beileid
und die toten die wir an diesen tagen
haben sind für uns alle ein großes drama
und natürlich wollen wir die zahlen der
toten wieder runter kriegen so haben wir
die impfstrategie angelegt dass wir ganz
klar gesagt haben wir wollen als
allererstes die hochbetagten auch die in
den pflegeheimen impfen und so haben wir
ja auch begonnen mit dem impfen
das wäre natürlich dadurch dass eben in
israel sehr schnell geben wird auch
diese diskussion in deutschland haben
aber wir haben uns auf die europäische
union geeinigt wir wollen jetzt aber
ganz konkret ganzen konkret von kojak
bevor sie über die europäische union
sprechen ganz konkret die frage hat die
bundesregierung eine mitschuld
wir tun alles dafür um unsere alten
menschen zu schützen sowohl eben dass
wir sie im vorfeld schützen indem wir
eben zum beispiel test zur verfügung
stellen und personal bezahlen das
geimpft werden kann das eben auch der
eintrag in die
in heimen nicht mehr so stattfinden wir
tun alles dafür sie zu schützen und dass
sie nicht alle schöpfen können ist für
uns natürlich genau so ein drama wie für
jeden anderen auch das heißt wenn sie
genügend impfstoff bestellt hätten in
der bundesregierung gemeinsam mit der
europäischen union dann könnte die
großmutter von volg angeles noch leben
wir haben uns darauf geeinigt mit der
europäischen union zusammen impfstoff zu
bestellen ich glaube dass es auch nach
wie vor richtig dann eine pandemie kann
ein einzelnes land nicht in griff
kriegen dann wird es auch wieder ein
getragen und deswegen wir müssen auf wir
müssen auf jeden fall weiter alles dafür
tun dass wir gerade auch die alten
menschen schützen und so ist auch unsere
strategie angelegt herr lauterbach
müssen wir gerade ohnmächtig zusehen
dass so etwas passiert was von kenji
berichtet hat das eine das dass ihre
großmutter ins krankenhaus eingeliefert
wird dann mit corona stirbt unsere
impfquote im vergleich zu anderen
ländern ist katastrophal
warum passiert das in deutschland so ich
sage also die impfung ist ja hier nicht
die einzige person zu schützen auf einem
banner herzliches beileid aber
tatsächlich haben wir auch noch die ganz
klassischen schutzmaßnahmen wir müssen
halt verhindern dass sich jemand in der
klinik infiziert das mal dass ich
überhaupt nicht also indem wir dass wir
das tatsächlich so gewesen ist es
skandalös das darf einfach nicht
passieren dass jemand der hochrisiko
patient ist sondern der klinik sich noch
interessiert und ich kenne auch viele
kliniken wohl über monate in der kein
einziger fall dieser art beobachtet
worden ist und daher wäre es so ist dann
wird das natürlich auch fragen auf wie
sich die klinik gewesen des tourismus
mittlerweile gesagt werden die klinik
könne nicht passieren schützen und die
meisten wirklich guten kliniken den
gelingt das auch also solche fälle sind
haben dürfte eigentlich gar nicht
vorkommen das sage ich gar nicht alles
ist erlaubt aber lassen sie uns noch mal
ganz kurz beim impfstoff bleiben denn
die frage stellt sich ja also die
großmutter von frau kennt
ist noch nicht an einen impfstoff
gekommen es gab kein angebot für sie und
gleichzeitig hat vor kesha selbst ein
angebot in israel in ihrem alltag sich
impfen zu lassen sie haben gerade die
bilder von den kindern gesehen die
bereits geimpft werden was läuft schief
dass in israel sich so viel mehr
menschen schon impfen lassen können im
vergleich zu deutschland
ja es ist ja mittlerweile bekannt dass
sich union hat hier mit sehr wenig geld
sehr spät ins dorf gekauft hat und das
haben sie dann halt zur folge dass die
unternehmen also nur wenige standorte in
europa aufgebaut haben dass nur ein
einziger standort für biotech
funktioniert jetzt hat für die gesamte
europäische union
in bars und das moderne standort in
spanien oder kleiner standort in der
schwarzen dazu gekommen
da ist der standort noch nicht das heißt
also nachträglich gesehen aber das ist
jetzt mittlerweile das weiß mittlerweile
hat sich die also einfach strategie der
eu hasso suboptimale wiesent weil sie
hat nicht dazu geführt dass die firmen
in allen großen europäischen ländern
produktionsstätten aufgebaut haben
es wäre ja denkbar gewesen hätte man es
jetzt viel mehr geld in die hand
genommen hat wären die
produktionsstätten früher aufgebaut
worden
und das ist ja der grund weshalb auch in
den vereinigten staaten der ist
schneller gm fällen kann alleine von
biotech und moderner werden den
vereinigten staaten pro woche derzeit 18
millionen dosen produziert und wir
können mit einer lieferung von
vielleicht zwölf millionen dosen lisa
wartenberg hersteller bis ende märz
reichen
herr lindner sie fordern seit vielen
vielen wochen einen impf gipfel den gab
es bislang noch nicht aber wenn sie
jetzt den fall sehen von frau kensche
wenn sie sehen dass die alten weiter
sterben in den krankenhäusern in den
pflegeheimen
was ist ihr ganz konkreter ansatz was
können sie tun um das zu stoppen
ich will erst auf rock and chill mein
beileid aussprechen
meine oma mit 91 jahren ist ebenfalls
kürzlich verstorben vor weihnachten in
einem altenpflegeheim nicht an und mit
aber jetzt kürzlich hat es in diesem
heim auch einen sehr ernsthaften
ausbruch der krankheit gegeben
und das zeigt er uns haben wir das
erstens wir immer noch ein jahr seit
beginn der pandemie noch nicht wirksam
die risikogruppen schützen ich würde in
einem klaren wort offen aussprechen es
handelt sich hier um regierungsversagen
und das sogar mit einem gewissen vorsatz
denn die regierung hat über monate
unsere entsprechenden forderungen und
vorschläge im deutschen bundestag
zurückgewiesen
frau merkel sagte das gehe gar nicht
dabei geht es nicht um 27 millionen
menschen in gleicher weise zu schützen
es geht auch nicht darum menschen
wegzusperren sondern es geht um
maßnahmen wie und jetzt werde ich
konkret die fsp zwei masken pflicht die
früher hätte kommen müssen jetzt geht es
um die ausweitung von test strategien
nun wird wieder eingewendet von der
regierung na ja wir können ja nicht so
schnell testen uns fehlt das personal
ja was ist mit den tausenden
freiwilligen der bundeswert die
reservisten die gerne sich da
qualifizieren lassen würden schulen
lassen würden um dort zu helfen
wir haben also noch nicht die nationale
kraftanstrengung zum schutz der
wirklichen risikogruppen und das ist ein
gebot der der seiner moralischen
verantwortung aber zugleich wäre das
auch ein wichtiger einer der wichtigen
innovativen bausteine um das land nicht
nur zu schließen sondern auch weiter zu
öffnen
vk nichts nützen wenn sie das noch frau
kalisch ganz kurz kurzen möchtest direkt
weitergeben for culture kamen sie
vorsätzlich versagt wir haben sehr
frühzeitig alles dafür getan dass eben
vor ort da wo es umgesetzt werden muss
alle möglichkeiten zur verfügung
stehenden wir haben recht früh sowohl
das testen als ein effektiver test da
war möglich gemacht und wir haben eben
auch die für die personalkosten gesorgt
die umsetzung ist ein
sache die vor ort geschehen muss und
deswegen kann man sowieso auch in einem
land und das will ich an dieser stelle
auch sagen wir haben ein land wo 30
millionen menschen potenziell
risikopatienten sind und das ist
ungefähr die hälfte der bevölkerung und
deswegen ist es so einfach nicht dass
man einfach sagen kann wir schützen
jetzt ganz gezielt nur die alten wir
haben alles dafür getan dass eben auch
in den altenpflegeheimen wo das
natürlich daneben auch sich immer wieder
als hot spot gezeigt hat dass wir
frühzeitig da mittel an die hand gegeben
haben um es umzusetzen
aber wir sollten uns keine illusionen
machen wir müssen für die ganze
bevölkerung das virus und die anzahl
derer die die franken am entsprechen
über die alten und pflegeheime
vorschläge heimat aber beim impfstoff
muss man doch mal einfach ganz klar
sagen warum geben sie nicht zu ja wir
haben beim impfstoff versagt im
vergleich zu anderen ländern
erstmal muss ich sagen da wir als
bundesregierung unsere unterstützung
dafür gegeben haben dass überhaupt in
dieser geschwindigkeit ein impfstoff
entwickelt werden kann und auch die
frage des aufbaus von eigenen
produktionskapazitäten haben wir massiv
in deutschland mit eigenen mitteln
unterstützt wir haben uns und ich glaube
immer noch dass es sehr wichtig war uns
dann entschieden dass wir gemeinsam als
europäische union den impfstoff
bestellen denn am ende ist gerade auf
einem kontinent eine pandemie kann man
nicht national lösen eine pandemie kann
man nur im verbund miteinander lösen und
dass wir überhaupt heute schon darüber
reden dass wir impfstoff haben
im sommer war die diskussion noch eine
ganz andere da hieß es wenn wir im
sommer so weit sind dass wir einen
impfstoff haben dann noch ein schild vor
fernsehstationen wunsch ich möchte
betonen dass die produktionskapazitäten
knapp sind möchte sie noch mal mit
reinnehmen ins gespräch frau karin
schenk sagt wir sollen froh sein dass
überhaupt impfstoff da sind was sagen
sie dazu
was soll ich dazu sagen
ja witzig ist das stück bei dem versagen
der regierung wenn das paar ist ja da
ist was schief gelaufen da habe ich
selbst noch so ich habe bisher
eingeräumt wie das gelaufen ist aber ich
möchte zwei dinge hier einräumen
zunächst haben wir die schätze sie aber
es kann man also das ist das würde ich
an dieser stelle mich sagen das ist
nicht wirklich erlöst zu sagen die
regierung hätten mit vorsatz gehandelt
es ist das ist irre ich würde es ganz
viel passiert sein und man kann auch
viel kritisieren das ist klar aber der
regierung vor zuhört und sie hätte mit
vorsatz der sondern leute in den
pflegeeinrichtungen sterben lassen
das ist eine unverschämtheit das habe
ich so nicht wir haben uns genau sie
haben das so gesagt wir haben gesagt mit
vorsatz war jedoch blitze weil ihre
vorschläge nicht befolgt worden sind
wäre das vorsatz gewesen
das ist irre ehrlich gesagt dass der
client nicht würdig und das heute
protestiert man muss offen sagen dass es
keinem einzigen europäischen land
gelungen die ausbrüche in den
pflegeeinrichtungen zu verhindern dann
wird auch viel zu wenig darüber
gesprochen ältere leute brauchen ganz
ganz wenig wie röslers den pflegeheimen
sind und stecken sich schon an
es sind an den gemeinschaftsräumen und
in diesen gemeinschaften stecken die
stadt unter na da ist es keinem einzigen
europäischen land gelungen
es kann sein dass das mit antiken test
und er wird die zwei masken besser wird
aber auch dann wird die ausbrüche geben
weil die älteren leute die idealen
bewohner die können kann ja nicht mit
zwei mal ausgetragen das heißt wenn da
eine einzige infektion reinkommt zum
beispiel über eine negativ getestet ist
aber positiv ist
und der ist dann krank dann steckte das
in den gemeinschaftsräumen das gesamte
heimat kein einziges land europas hat es
geschafft die älteren komplett zu
schützen nicht einmal dass wir deutlich
besser werden müssen und ich habe das
auch immer vorschläge gemacht und
übrigens auch vorschläge von ihnen zum
teil gestützt und für richtigen aber
dann so etwas zu unterstellen ihre junge
wurde mit vorsatz die alten leute da
ich habe also bei lauterbach von ihnen
von ihnen war zunächst mal keine
kopfnoten um das mal klarzustellen und
was andere sagen ob das würdig ist oder
nicht also die zitate von ihnen wo man
die würde frage stellen kann sind auch
region was ich gesagt habe ist es gibt
einen regierungsversagen mit vorsatz und
zwar in dem sinne dass frau merkel im
deutschen bundestag wie auch gerade hier
frau carlitscheck den eindruck erweckt
hat es handelt sich um 27,3 5 millionen
menschen und die kann man ja gar nicht
so schützen
deshalb müsste man in der breite
freiheits einschränkungen beschließen
diese zitate finden sie zuhauf in den
protokollen des deutschen bundestages
und das ist für mich nicht die nationale
kraftanstrengung die wir brauchen zum
schutz der alten und jetzt uns konkret
zu machen
sie haben es ja gerade auch eingeräumt
viele vorschläge sind unterbreitet
worden
ffp zwei masken für alle die dort zugang
haben also pflegepersonal
reinigungskräfte schnelltests all das
kam viel zu spät die sogar der
vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion eingeräumt
hat und das muss dringend beseitigt
werden es hilft ja nichts zurück zu
schauen wir müssen jetzt schnell die
entsprechenden mittel treffen und sie
haben wir einigen gesprochen
hier müssen wir feststellen das kind ist
in den brunnen gefallen ist hilft uns
aber nichts jetzt zu beklagen was
letztes jahr im sommer nicht gut
gelaufen ist müssen wir schauen was geht
jetzt besser und hierzu habe ich zwei
vorschläge der erste vorschlag ist wir
müssen jetzt bund länder die landkreise
die niedergelassenen ärztinnen und ärzte
und die pharmazeutische industrie an
einem tisch bringen und überlegen wie
kann die logistik alleine schon besser
werden beim impfen wenn ich höre dass
hochbetagte menschen hohe 80 mit dem
taxi und den dem rollator zum ins
zentrum fahren dort dann möglicherweise
stehend warten müssen dann noch eine
längere
wartung bekommen bevor sie geimpft sind
dann muss das besser und leichter
organisiert werden und zum zweiten haben
markus söder und ich übrigens auch teile
der spd ja dringend vorgeschlagen mit
der pharmazeutischen industrie darüber
zu sprechen die wir die
impfstoffproduktion erhöhen können alle
nachdem bisher nicht genutzte
kapazitäten eingesetzt werden
das ist jetzt wieder wochen her wo sind
die initiativen von herrn spahn ich bin
mir darüber im klaren man kann die
produktion von aspirin nicht morgen auf
impfstoff umstellen aber wenn frau
merkel inzwischen vom 21 september
spricht bis wir allen erwachsenen
menschen allen menschen an im angebot
unterbreitet haben dann ist jeder monat
ist jede woche die wir schneller sind
potentiell geeignet leben zu schützen
und sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
schaden zu reduzieren frau fischer ich
möchte sie gerne noch mal mit reinnehmen
ins gespräch denn sie haben genau das
erlebt in den vergangenen tagen und
wochen wie es in deutschen
krankenhäusern zugegangen ist und wieder
schutz eben nicht um
erklären sie uns noch einmal konkret wie
ist es ihrer großmutter da in dem
deutschen krankenhaus ergangen
also wurde und zwischen hier nur
eingeliefert hatte wasser in der lunge
und herz rhythmus störungen und war dann
auch den normalen station und da wurden
zwei test gemacht also im schnitt jetzt
unten abstriche und pcr test und die
wand negativ und acht tage später mutter
noch ein test gemacht und der war auf
einmal positiv also bei der lauterbacher
sagte wenn das so stimmt also
das deutet eindeutig darauf hin und
gegenüber meinen eltern haben mir als
das wohl auch gesagt dass das so im
krankenhaus passiert sei dass sie dort
angesteckt wurde und das ja also
erstaunt mich ja wenn ich das jetzt so
moderat ausdrücken darf dass er jemand
im krankenhaus als einem jahr diese
pandemie wieder sein kann ja dass so ein
buch gefährdete menschen krankenhaus
angesteckt wird und was mich auch
erstaunt ist dann tatsächlich wie wir
schon hinnehmen
also wir nehmen das alles so hin dass
das halt passiert wir können die leute
leider so gibt es da zu wenig impfstoff
ist leider doof ich habe dann aus meinem
ersten stock heraus vergessen dass
gezittert weil ich es einfach unfassbar
finde dass in diesen anfangs so passiert
und dann kriege ich tatsächlich
reaktionen wie da war doch schon 91
wer jetzt noch 130 geboren oder was also
ich finde es unfassbar wie abgestoßen
mittlerweile sind und dass auch eine
recht deutsche diskussion dass dann
teilweise gesagt wird ja die leute sind
ja schon alt und da so rechnung
aufgemacht werden ab das leben noch wert
ist also das hab ich jetzt hier in
israel auch so nicht erlebt zum beispiel
im vergleich pokale check von grenze
sagt wir nehmen das einfach so hinnehmen
sie das als teil der regierung zu locker
nehmen sie das einfach so hin was in
deutschland passiert vor allem wenn man
drauf blick dass diese pandemie eben
bereits seit zwölf monaten fast andauert
ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand
angesichts der hohen todeszahlen die wir
im moment zu beklagen haben abgestumpft
ist im gegenteil wir sind immer und
immer wieder im sehr engen austausch
gerade auch mit den ländern wirklich zu
überlegen was können wir denn noch tun
wo können wir dennoch unterstützen dass
wir diese todeszahlen runter kriegen den
verstärkten locker und den wir jetzt
geschlossen haben haben wir genau aus
diesem grunde beschlossen weil das wirkt
das letzte wirksame mittel was wir am
ende haben ist immer weiter runter zu
fahren und damit im grunde auch die
bevölkerung mit ins boot zu nehmen und
alles dafür zu tun dass diese
ansteckungskette nicht weiterlaufen und
jetzt sehen wir uns gerade auch noch der
mutation gegenüber von der wir auch noch
nicht wissen inwieweit sie im grunde
dieses geschehen noch mal verstärkt wir
haben in den ganzen monaten immer und
immer wieder alles dafür getan um eben
diese zweite welle auch möglichst
einzudämmen
aber so ehrlich muss man sein es ist
eben eine sehr sehr schwierige
gemengelage wenn man eben guckt in den
altenheimen
die instanz sein so hoch sind dann ist
immer mal wieder die möglichkeit dass
irgendwo etwas durchrutscht und ich will
an dieser stelle auch einmal denen die
in den krankenhäusern verantwortung
tragen den rücken stärken ich glaube
niemand nimmt da irgendwie billigend in
kauf dass sich jemand an steckt aber wir
sollten bei diesen hohen incident zahlen
auch so ehrlich sein das ist sehr sehr
schwer ist 100% zu gewährleisten dass da
sich niemand irgendwo ansteckt wir sehen
ja wie schwierig es ist diese ganzen
infektionsketten unter kontrolle zu
halten und wie schwer ist auch ist es
aus dem altenheim und aus den
krankenhäusern rauszuhalten
wir haben jetzt gerade gesehen dass ein
ganzes krankenhaus geschlossen ist
niemand nimmt das billigend in kauf wir
sehen dass wir sehen das genau wie sie
dass das ein drama ist und das ist ja
das warum wir alles dafür tun um diese
hohen inzidenz seien wieder runter zu
bekommen
kränze zum abschluss vielleicht ganz
schnell was wünschen sie sich von der
deutschen politik was jetzt gemacht wird
damit sich so viele fälle nicht
wiederholen damit nicht noch weitere
oder nicht in dem ausmaß weitere alte
menschen vor allem in deutschland
sterben
was soll ich also weiß ganz klar ist es
muss an der verteilung gearbeitet werden
also was ich da lese und höre auch um
eben mit bekomme das funktioniert nicht
und wir haben gerade sehr wenig
impfstoff in deutschland und die
verteilung funktioniert nicht wie soll
das erst sein wenn dann hoffentlich mal
mehr nachkommt und ich denke auch dass
ja das ist ein großes fass aber da zeigt
sich doch wie wenig vorangeschritten wie
digitalisierungen in deutschland ist und
ich denke es wird uns über diese krise
noch hinaus begleiten dass das land sich
da besser aufstellen muss und ja ich
wünsche mir dass daran gearbeitet wird
und darüber transparent gesprochen wird
herzlichen dank christine kensche für
diese dramatische geschichte und ich
wünsche ihnen in diesen tagen besonders
viel kraft in israel und alles gute
herzlichen dank porsche hat es
angesprochen impfstoff verteilung ist
das entscheidende thema in deutschland
und ich möchte darüber mit
landrat sprechender dass in diesem
moment erlebt das ist nämlich im
vergleich insbesondere zu israel in
deutschland viel zu wenig impfstoff gibt
und mir sehr zugeschaltet stefan
sternberg landrat aus ludwigslust
schönen guten abend herr sternberg sie
stehen im impfzentrum bei ihnen was war
da los was ist denn da los und was wird
da los sein
ja ich hoffe ihr wird bald ganz viel los
sein denn im moment ist hier wirklich
wenig los wir haben im kapazitäten
aufgebaut von bis zu 1500 impfungen am
tag 350 pro im zentrum und dann mobile
teams für den ländlichen raum
organisiert wir haben lange mit der
landesregierung über das konzept
gesprochen und jetzt bin ich seit tagen
eigentlich die person an der spitze des
landkreises die entscheiden muss mit dem
wenigen impfdosen wäre dann zuerst dran
ist und das sorgt natürlich in der
bevölkerung für eine wirklich schwierige
situation und man machen sie da sie
nicht wie machen sie das sie sagen das
gibt ihnen schlaflose nächte heißt es am
ende
sie müssen darüber entscheiden wer die
pandemie überlebt und wer nicht wenn sie
sagen das macht ihn schlaflose nächte
ich höre dass ich kann dem stern so
sagen dass wir alle unsere pflegeheime
in den ersten also jetzt in den ersten
wochen einmal durchgekämpft haben wir
beginnen jetzt mit dem zweiten mal und
jetzt wird der impfstoff runtergefahren
das ist ein riesenproblem
und wir gehen nach einem festen cluster
was wir entwickelt haben für unseren
landkreis und es funktioniert es
funktioniert dass wir impfen können und
ich hätte wenn der impfstoff so gekommen
wäre wir zum anfang zugesagt worden wäre
letzten freitag im landkreis mit
pflegeeinrichtungen und krankenhäusern
durch sein können das tut er aber nicht
dann wenn ich so wie für die letzte
woche in 900 dosen zur verfügung habe
für den zweitgrössten flächenland kreis
in deutschland und nächste woche nur 350
dann wissen sie in welcher situation wir
sind und ich will noch mal eins ganz
deutlich sagen auch in richtung herr
lindner
ich kann es nicht mehr hören dass
darüber gesprochen wird dass wir nicht
vorbereitet sind berlin muss die
hausaufgaben
und mir ist auch ehrlich gesagt egal
welche partei das ist denn wir sind hier
vor ort ich fange das ab und ich sage
ihnen ich kann als landrat nicht mal
mehr einkaufen gehen weil jeder hat eine
traurige geschichte einer oma einer
tante einer mama eines papas der geimpft
werden muss der transplantierten organe
hat der eine krebserkrankung hinter sich
hat das ist hochgradig frustrierend was
gerade passiert und ich bin ganz doll
unglücklich berlin war noch nie so weit
weg obwohl es nur zwei autostunden sind
von ludwigslust parchim gehen diesen
wochen einstellen wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
also das heißt ja auch gleichzeitig dass
die impfbereitschaft bei ihnen im
landkreis der so hoch ist und die
menschen unbedingt an impfstoff kommen
wollen also sie werden dann auf der
straße angesprochen im supermarkt
erzählen sie uns wie läuft das da ab
damit berlin mal versteht was da los ist
das ist es so wenn wir das erste mal
neben pflegeeinrichtungen waren und wir
haben viele tolle landärzte akquirieren
können die in die pflegeheime gehen mit
als in unserem team und mit den alten
älteren menschen sprechen auch mit dem
personal sprechen und wir haben
pflegeheime hinbekommen bei der
erstimpfung von 96 prozent durch
impfungen ich finde es ein wahnsinnig
tolles ergebnis und wir haben dann zum
zweiten termin jetzt die erfahrung dass
sogar noch mehr sich impfen lassen
wollen also die letzten vier
weil wir einfach auch diese empfangs ein
stück weit weg geräumt haben und es ist
ja so dass wir hier in den impfzentren
auch mit einem brief arbeiten an die
über 80-jährigen die verschickt werden
nach alphabet und die dann eingeladen
werden aber wir mussten zum beispiel für
die nächste woche komplette time slots
wieder abmelden weil wir keinen
impfstoff mehr haben und glauben sie mir
wenn eine 90-jährige dame sich durch die
hotline gequält hat ihren termin
bekommen hat licht am ende des tunnels
sieht und dann kommt aus berlin das
signal es gibt weniger impfstoff dann
sind wir diejenigen die die botschaft
rüberbringen müssen und sagen
entschuldigung wir müssen den termin
absagen
und darum wird man in der bevölkerung
angesprochen
der frust ist riesig weil das impfen ist
ja so wie wir es immer ein erzielt haben
das licht am ende des tunnels und die
ganzen maßnahmen die fangen wir die kita
schließen
die schulschließung ich muss das mit
allgemeinverfügung mit meiner
unterschrift vertreten und
dementsprechend werden selbst die besten
freunde
die jetzt im home office zu hause sitzen
mit drei kindern manchmal nicht mehr so
die besten freunde weil den menschen die
nerven einfach bedienen
herr lauter bei lauterbach sie hören die
ausführungen wie frustrierend ist das
für sie als teil ja auch der koalition
dass das so kolossal schiefgegangen ist
natürlich extrem frustrierend dass nicht
wie er jetzt offen da ist übrigens
dieser liegt bist du die es jetzt gibt
von bayern tag war das werk umfasst auch
so vergrößert wird die auch so werden
nur relativ kurze zeit an achten aber
wir haben halt das größte problem das
man darf man davon ausgehen muss dass
wir bis ende juni nicht in der lage sein
werden der gesamten band kurz machen
dieses bereitschaft ist jetzt schon oben
die wird weiter steigen natürlich ich
brauche eben auch mit dem kollegen von
der kölner uniklinik wie hoch die
endspiel bei meinen kollegen ist und
auch weil der pflegekassen 95 prozent
sind können der uniklinik bereit sich
impfen zu lassen das kombinieren das
wird natürlich frustrierend sein bei dem
monate hinweg immer wieder sagen zu
müssen es kommt mehr im stau es gibt
nicht viele aber das problem ist jetzt
ja wurden geschrieben worden
somit also bringt dann nichts anders aus
als das was wir jetzt machen wir müssen
dann versuchen mit einem effizienten
guten lockt die zahl nochmal so ein
sonder zu bekommen dass wir die familien
den griff bekommen so dass wir mehr zeit
zum essen haben das ist die ehrliche
wahrheit wir werden einen engagierten
und gut funktionieren dann doch ein paar
weil insbesondere die neuen varianten
die jetzt kommen zu denen ich auch gerne
etwas sagen leute denn die gelegenheit
bestünden diese von einem ganz anderen
kaliber das ist noch einmal eine ganz
andere hausnummer
wir haben noch mal ein ganz anderes
bedrohungspotenzial und wir müssen uns
also erfahrungen führen das können wir
nicht weg kämpfen sondern das kommt
bevor wir
genug menschen in deutschen dort in
deutschland haben können werden wir
diese drei varianten in deutschland
abend bei lauterbach herr drosten hat
von der osten hat bereits gewarnt dass
der sommer nicht so sein wird wie wir
uns ihn vielleicht wünschen und hat von
über 100.000 fällen gesprochen durch
auch die mutation die da auf uns zukommt
wie sehen sie das
das ist durchaus sollst du denkbar ich
hoffe dass das nicht so komme ich auch
mit ihm gesprochen nach seinen
überlegungen ist im prinzip die wenn die
menschen in den pflegeeinrichtungen in
not sind und auch die über 80-jährigen
dann könnte die bereitschaft also zum
also zu den normalen schutzmaßnahmen aus
der maske tankstellen der gastronomie
nicht auf diese bereiche auch die könnte
danach nehmen und wenn diese bereits auf
abnimmt dann werden die drei rotationen
die das hinterland die drei varianten
die ja aus an vier stellen wo diese die
werden sich dann so schnell verraten so
schnell kann man nicht schauen
diese varianten haben alle eines
gemeinsam die ansteckung
wahrscheinlichkeit ist so viel höher
das auch das besser werdende wetter uns
da nicht ein ich glaube dass das das ist
was christian osten auch hier im comfort
aus so dass er sich vorstellen kann dass
leute glauben das ist so wie beim
letzten mal im sommer das wetter wurde
besser wir hatten wenige fälle dann ist
das gerade zurückgegangen dort kann man
hier bei diesen drei varianten nicht
auch so errechnet also das geht wie das
warme messer durch die butter werden
noch so beispielsweise die a1 bei warmem
wetter sich ausbreitet dann außen sind
infektionszahlen extrem hoch man muss
davon ausgehen dass auf einen monat
betrachtet diese drei feiern sechs bis
acht mal so ansteckend sind und wenn ich
dann die jetzigen zahlen hoch recht da
bin ich schnell bei dem szenario was
christa kosten vorgerechnet hat ich sage
ich hoffe dass das nicht konnte ich
hoffe dass wir werden hier sollte das
kommen sehen
dennoch dauern entsprechend anpassen ich
glaube also wie das wir aber trotzdem
diese gefahr sehen müssen die drei war
ja werden nicht weggehen weil das
interesse werden pokale check können wir
den sommer schon abschreiben aus ihrer
sicht wenn sie das jetzt hören auch was
die mutationen angeht was hören sie
und die zweite frage wenn es im sommer
so katastrophal sein sollte dann werden
auch die fragen noch lauter an die
bundesregierung was da an die schief
gelaufen ist im vergangenen sommer bei
der impfstoff bestellung und sie waren
beteiligt daran bei und tag millionen-
zur forschung zu geben aber anders als
von anderen ministern verlangt haben sie
keine gegenleistung verlangt in dem
moment warum eigentlich nicht warum
haben sie nicht gesagt wenn wir so viele
millionen dafür die forschung ausgeben
dann wollen wir ein so genanntes
vorkaufsrecht ich will mal vielleicht
die erste frage beantworten diese
gestellt haben nein wir müssen den
sommer nicht abschreiben aber wir müssen
uns darüber im klaren sein dass wir je
besser wir jetzt von den hohen inzidenz
zahlen runter kommen und je vorsichtiger
wir dann sind je besser wir es schaffen
die nachvollziehbarkeit wieder zu
gewährleisten
umso mehr können wir uns über den sommer
erlauben und deswegen ist es jetzt
glaube ich wichtig dass wir zum einen in
den nächsten drei wochen die zahlen
möglichst weit drücken können also eben
auch möglichst weit unter 50 und dass
wir dann wenn wir uns danach wieder
etwas mehr erlauben können dass wir dann
ganz klar sagen wir gehen sehr
vorsichtig daran wir werden weiterhin
gene konzepte masken tragen und so
weiter in den mittelpunkt stellen und
dann wird es vielleicht ein etwas
anderer sommer aber dann werden wir uns
über den sommer doch das eine oder
andere leisten können wir müssen uns nur
im klaren sein
die erleichterungen durch den sommer das
sind 20 prozent dessen was uns im grunde
an möglichkeiten zur verfügung steht und
deswegen ist das drücken der inzidenz
oder der infektionszahlen und auch das
nachvollziehen das einzige was uns jetzt
im moment wirklich hilft damit wir dann
eben auch das ein oder andere wieder uns
erlauben können apocalypse ganz gut wenn
sie wenn sie wenn sie mehr impfstoff
bestellt hätten dann hätten wir einen
guten sommer vor uns also ist es doch
die schuld der bundesregierung
die frage nach dem impfstoff impfstoff
zu produzieren ist eine echte hightech
produktion und da kann ich auch nicht
mal eben eine weitere produktionslinie
aufsetzen wir haben schon im sommer
unsere unterstützung gegeben damit bayon
tag eben eine weitere produktionslinie
oder eine weitere produktion in
deutschland aufbauen kann dass wir eben
auch eine eigene produktion hier in
deutschland bekommen die produktion die
wir jetzt haben ist ja eben entweder
über pfizer in den usa oder auch in
belgien und deswegen wir haben damals
die förderung auf den weg gebracht damit
die impfstoff entwicklungen möglichst
zügig geht aber man muss immer wissen
dass eben bei einer förderung wie wir
sie auf den weg bringen keine
gegenleistung gefordert werden da war
warum du nicht das verstecken können das
versteht doch kein mensch pokal check
das versteht doch kein mensch wie vor
wir fördern will ihr euer geld bei antec
und wir können dann keine wir können
dann keine gegenleistung bekommen dafür
nein wir können keinen zweiseitigen
vertrag über unsere förderung machen wir
haben uns aber mit der firma bei unter-
oder beziehungsweise mit allen dreien
die wir gefördert haben wir haben ja
auch koubek und biologika gefördert wir
haben mit denen vereinbart dass sie
einen teil der produktion daneben auch
in deutschland zur verfügung stellen
einen vertrag über einen kauf kann nur
und so hat es ja das bmg dann auch
gemacht das bundesministerium für
gesundheit dass sie einem eu
abgeschlossen haben mit den firmen denen
wir die förderung gegeben haben und so
haben wir hand in hand
zusammengearbeitet
das werk abschließend noch einmal zu
ihnen wenn sie das ja gleich wird zur
lindner wir kommen auch gleich wieder zu
ihnen aber einmal zu erstellen wird
nochmal da kommen wir auch zu erstellen
berg wenn sie diese diskussion in berlin
so haben sie es ja auch beschrieben
erleben was denken sie und vor allem was
glauben sie müsste hier passieren damit
es ihnen als landrat und ihren menschen
die sich jetzt impfen wollen besser geht
[Musik]
ganz klar die motivation in der
bevölkerung bleibt genau bis zu dem
punkt wo man weiß es gibt ein angebot
was da ist und wir brauchen dies im
angebot
und wir brauchen impfstoff das ist das
entscheidende
herr lindner sie wollten noch etwas
sagen ich glaube das ist klar wir
brauchen impfstoff zwei dinge wollte ich
gern zum 1
ich halte es nicht für realistisch wie
es hier angedeutet worden ist von frau
karla check und herrn lauterbach dass
wir den jetzigen lockdown oder gar einen
schärferen noch bis in den sommer
fortsetzen
ich sehe dass die stimmung in der
bevölkerung sich verändert hat es gibt
eine große ungeduld die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen schäden wachsen
ich denke an wird er gleich noch ein
thema sein an kita und schule
wir müssen also jetzt nach einem jahr
mittwoch ist das einjährige datum des
ersten patienten in deutschland der
ersten erkannt wir müssen auf eine
andere strategie wechseln
mit intelligenten mitteln
gesundheitsschutz und zumindest
regionale öffnungen zu verbinden und zu
hören sternberg der hatte nicht eben
angesprochen als er davon sprach berlin
ist so weit weg vom rest des landes wie
nie zuvor spricht er nicht an dabei bin
ich exakt dieser meinung
das ist ja genau der grund warum wir
einen impf gipfel fordern wo die ebene
der landkreise mit dabei ist im übrigen
auch die niedergelassenen ärztinnen und
ärzte denn auch die fach und hausärzte
werden wir in den nächsten wochen und
monaten einbeziehen müssen um sehr
schnell niedrigschwellig unbürokratisch
und für die menschen leichter die
impfungen vorzunehmen
und ich will noch mal zuletzt
unterstreichen frau kathi check hat ja
gesagt man kann das nicht weiter
beschleunigen
ich empfehle uns dass wir bei der frage
können wir die produktion ausweiten
nicht zu früh kapitulieren sich ja bei
und tag ist ein sehr spezieller
impfstoff über die gehen schere
entstanden es gibt aber jetzt auch bald
andere impfstoffe die zugelassen sind
die in der produktion möglicherweise
weniger aufwendig sind und hier will ich
noch mal unterstreichen herr söder und
ich auch der carsten schneider von der
spd haben dringend den
gesundheitsminister gebeten mit der
pharmazeutischen industrie zusammen zu
kommen und zu überlegen wie können wir
die produktion ausweiten
da geht es nicht um enteignung von
geistigem eigentum
aber wie können wir die möglichkeiten
haben die möglichkeiten nutzen die wir
haben
guckt mal in erinnerung auch bei und tec
hat ja gerade erst in marburg ein neues
werk eröffnet das besitzen die auch
nicht fünf jahre sondern wenige monate
und das zeigt mir wir dürfen nicht
warten auf den 21 september den frau
merkel genannt hat es ist möglich auch
schneller zu impfen und da erwarten die
menschen wirklich ambition etwa bei der
frage wie schließen wir das land herr
sternberg schnelle antwort sie haben mit
dem kopf geschüttelt
er ist ganz einfach so man braucht nicht
mehr mit der kommunalen ebene reden weil
also natürlich sollten wir immer
miteinander reden aber ich hab so ein
bisschen das gefühl dass hier auch ein
stück weit auf uns abgeschoben werden
soll wir sind vorbereitet hätten
man hat mit uns gesprochen wir haben mit
den hausärzten gesprochen unsere
ministerpräsidentin trifft sich mit uns
alle 14 tage in einem sogenannten mv
gipfel das also dass es ein schritt zu
spät
den brauchen wir nicht mehr wir brauchen
den schritt impfstoff in deutschland für
die risikogruppen und dann kann unsere
gesellschaft auch wieder anfangen alles
andere was wir hier diskutieren
das ist richtig aber sie sind auch zum
teil nebel gefechte und das geht ja gar
nicht nur gegen einen linzer bitte nicht
falsch verstehen oder gar nicht gegen
herrn lindner
wir brauchen klarheit wir brauchen
verlässliche liefermengen damit wir
unsere bürger ein bestellen können weil
am ende bin nicht der landrat der in ein
pflegeheim wo 120 menschen leben 96 aus
brücke hat und 20 todesopfer und ich
muss es verantworten
klare ansage aus ludwigslust wir
brauchen dringend impfstoff herzlichen
dank für ihre klaren worte und ich
wünsche ihnen das schnell neuer
impfstoff kommt und dass sie dann mit
den impfungen auch tatsächlich
weitermachen können herzlichen dank ich
möchte direkt weitermachen mit einer
schalte zu herrn homburg christian
homburg der sich ebenfalls verlassen
fühlt von der politik und komplett
vergessen hamburg sie sind hoch
risikopatient und sie leben zu 90
prozent zu hause
deswegen bekommen sie keine impfungen
sie fühlen sich deshalb vergessen
erklären sie uns bitte ihren fall und
vor allem bis vielen an
in deutschland geht ja also erstmal bin
ich halt schwer pflegebedürftig und
hochrisiko fall aufgrund meiner
neuromuskulären erkrankung
muskeldystrophie duchenne das ist ein
fortschreitender muskelschwund der mich
größtenteils bewegungsunfähig gemacht
und sich halt auch auf herz und lunge
auswirkt das heißt ich habe nur noch ein
volumen von etwa 20 prozent und werde
bereits den schon am tag beatmet also
mediziner haben bereits im märz vor
meiner erkrankung gesagt wir sollen uns
isolieren und kontakt vermeiden
gut es eben geht eben weil schon normale
erkältung wie jemanden wie mich der
gefährlichsten und schnell zu
lungenentzündung führen können also ist
bei mir schon von einem hohen
sterberisiko auszugehen
die besonderheit ist jetzt aber ich bin
also wirklich schwer isoliert aber das
ist leider auch nur sehr begrenzt
möglich weil ich nämlich den
höchstmöglichen grad habe und ich lebe
heute einem selbstbestimmten
pflegemodell jedenfalls schon das ist es
genannt
das heißt ich beschäftige selbst ein
team aus neun teils gelernten als
ungelernte kräfte die nicht pflege
unterstützen ich bin halt auch immer auf
sie angewiesen und dadurch trotzdem
einen erhöhten risiko einer infektion
ausgesetzt bevor weiter zu sagen also
sterberisiko und infektionsrisiko die
zwei großen kriterien die von der stiko
auch für die impfverordnung benutzt
wurde
wird also hier hinlänglich gegeben und
dennoch tauchen kälte wie ich gar nicht
in der impfung auf wie kann das sein
volk alle check dass jemand wie herr
homburg dem hohen risiko ausgesetzt ist
er jetzt auch eine petition gestartet
hat schon 50.000 menschen haben da
unterschrieben diese petition geht bald
an gesundheitsminister sparen aber
vielleicht können sie schon mal sagen
wurde er vergessen wie tausende andere
in deutschland also über die frage wer
wann geimpft wird und wie das in den
risikogruppen eingeteilt wird ist ja
sehr sehr intensiv gesprochen worden wir
haben die arbeitsgruppe gehabt wo die
ständige impfkommission mit dem ethikrat
und auch der leopoldina wirklich auch um
eine gute lösung und um eine gute eine
gute priorisierung gerungen hat und sie
sagen jetzt gute lösungen zwischen sie
sagen jetzt gute lösung das kann ja
keine gute lösung sein dass herr homburg
der schwer gefährdet ist keine impfung
bekommt
wir sehen noch im moment das impfstoff
knapp ist und man muss dann irgendwo
anfangen und die meisten bundesländer
sind hingegangen und haben erst mal in
ihren pflege pflegeheimen geimpft weil
da natürlich auch die großen ausbrüche
waren und wenn wir jetzt einen impfstoff
demnächst haben der auch leichter zu
transportieren ist dass man dann eben
auch über die hausärzte dann impfen kann
dann gibt es ja eben auch die
möglichkeit daneben diejenigen die zu
hause sind und eben nicht transportabel
sind das die dann auch relativ früh
geimpft werden wir müssen uns einfach in
dieser situation auch verschiedene wege
einigen und das ein das eine ist dass
wir die isolierung und den schutz eben
über über testen und eben auch über
masken tragen und diese dinge möglich
machen und das andere ist dass wir in
der reihenfolge wie wir jetzt vorgesehen
haben zu impfen uns immer wieder
abgleichen wie ist das dann auch mit der
logistik der impfstoffe überhaupt
möglich am ende ist es jetzt ein
gemeinsamer kraftakt und ich glaube
jetzt den einen gegen den anderen
auszuspielen das hilft uns in dieser
situation überhaupt nicht weiter laut
aber es geht ja nicht darum jemanden
gegeneinander auszuspielen sondern wir
haben mit herrn homburg jemand der neben
verzweifelt um diese impfung bittet wo
eine petition gestartet hat was würden
sie ihm jetzt raten was soll er tun und
was können sie dafür tun dass jemand wie
homburg eine info bekommt sondern ich
sage so ich finde die grundsätzliche
stiko empfehlungen die wir ja umsetzen
die sind wichtig auf der anderen seite
werde ich persönlich der meinung dass
für menschen die herausnahme nötig sein
sollten es gibt tatsächlich eine extrem
gefährdete gruppe auch von jüngeren
menschen die also bei der erkrankung
also ein sehr hohes risiko tragen würden
und also dass diese gruppe priorisierung
das hielte ich was aus der
gesundheitspolitik hielte ich das doch
so für wichtig und würde das begrüßen
das neue ist dass ich in der empfehlung
der stiko nicht darin gewesen
das ist da die haben das auch ausgefüllt
es hat sie das nicht aufgegriffen haben
es sehr schwer umzusetzen
aber auch nach gewichtung dieser gründe
wäre ich der meinung dass solche
ausnahmen zugelassen werden sollten
wir starten sie mir nur einen einzigen
satz noch kurz im plus so wichtig ich
habe nicht verlangt und noch nicht
vorgesehen dass wir bis das so september
oder bis zum sommer im loch drin bleiben
dass ich wieder gesagt noch fände ich
das richtig das ist nicht meine meinung
habe ich nicht gesagt uns ständig auch
falsch herr homburg zum abschluss reicht
ihnen das was sie hier hören von der
politik von der bundesministerin von der
lauterbach der teil der regierung sind
was erhoffen sie sich was die politiker
für sie und für andere in deutschland
tun können also erst mal wollte ich noch
ein bisschen ergänzen also erstmal geht
es überhaupt nicht warum hier
unterschiedliche erkrankungen aus dem
haus zu spielen oder sich vor zu bringen
oder sonstiges ist leider so dass wir
nicht nur bei der im punkt vergessen
wurden wellen ambulanter pflege sondern
auch eigentlich bei allen maßnahmen
systematisch vergessen wurden
und zwar haben wir keine
schutzausrüstung für personal oder
pflegende angehörige bekommen
wir haben keinen schnelltest bekommen
keine pflege bonus unsere gelehrten
kräfte und nun also auch keine schnelle
impfung also ist einiges
zusammengekommen und genau deswegen habe
ich die petition gestartet
um dafür aufmerksamkeit hier liegt eine
echte notlage vor
das muss man jetzt mal hier so deutlich
sagen es ist doch völlig richtig dass in
pflegeeinrichtungen mit der impfung
begonnen wird hier ist das
infektionsrisiko natürlich noch höher
weil da ja auch noch ein mitbewohner
sind die ist jetzt in unseren fällen
nicht aber trotzdem sind wir in
ständiger gefahr in ständiger angst es
geht halt nicht um diese isolierung oder
einschränkung ja jetzt jeder weil diese
ständige angst und jetzt bei den crooner
varianten die uns jetzt bevorstehen
das ist halt wirklich schwierig und was
man ja auch dazu sagen muss bei der die
wie in den empfehlungen sind wir sehr
wohl berücksichtigt worden
da heißt es nämlich da geht es um den
klinischen erfolgsaussichten
die sind beim eugh muss klären
andere sind wieder explizit aufgeführt
dass die schlechter sind das heißt wenn
es jetzt eine variante zum ausbruch
kommen dann könnte sogar sein dass wir
dann nicht mal behandelt werden lokale
check da muss ich doch noch mal
nachfragen was können sie jetzt
persönlich tun um da was zu machen wie
wer hat da versagt wenn wirklich auch in
der vergangenheit bei den tests nicht
ankamen
was ja was er homburg der gesagt hat was
hat der bundesgesundheitsminister der
falsch gemacht
ich habe jetzt das was was daher gesagt
hat nur zu ganz kleinen teilen
verstanden insofern kann ich jetzt
einfach nur noch mal darauf eingehen
dass es eben eine priorisierung gegeben
hat und dass man jetzt einfach anfängt
und dass man eben vielleicht auch
verordnen einfach noch mal darauf
aufmerksam machte
am ende hilft gerade eben bei solchen
fällen wie sie ihn jetzt gerade
beschreiben eine pragmatische lösung vor
ort und dann muss man einfach auch
gucken wie geht man vor ort vernünftig
damit um
es bringt doch nicht immer nur zu sagen
wir machen jetzt etwas für alle und wir
haben an den einzelnen an den ein oder
anderen fall nicht gedacht wichtig ist
doch dass sie hilfe bekommen und das
muss man halt vor ort jetzt schnell und
gut organisieren und dass sie eben
vielleicht auch noch mal die frage der
testung ich glaube sie haben eben gesagt
sie haben ja mehr personal was zu ihnen
kommt und dass die eben auch regelmäßig
möglichkeiten haben getestet zu werden
so wie das eben in den altenheimen auch
möglich ist aber ich glaube das ist bei
so einem schweren fall wie bei ihnen
auch ganz pragmatisch vor ort doch
möglich hamburg ich verspreche ihnen wir
von bild bleiben da dran wir werden
weiter über das berichten was sie tun
mit ihrer petition und wir werden auch
dem bundesgesundheitsministerium und vor
allem dem grund
bundesgesundheitsminister in den
nächsten tagen diese fragen stellen
herzlichen dank und ich wünsche ihnen
alles alles alles gute
danke falls ja abseits von der schweren
frage was mit impfungen in deutschland
passiert abseits davon dass es zu wenig
impfstoff in deutschland gibt gibt es
eine weitere ganz ganz große debatte
nämlich die frage was mit unseren
schulen passiert und es gab in den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder
forderungen
die schulen zu öffnen jetzt ist klar die
schulen und kitas bleiben dicht pokale
check wenn sie jetzt die situation von
deutschlands schülern sehen deutschland
schülerinnen und schülern und auch in
den kitas
wie erleben sie diese situation in als
ministerin und glauben sie was glauben
sie wielange muss die müssen die schulen
noch geschlossen bleiben
also wir sie in dem moment zunehmend
dass eben gerade bei den hohen
infektionszahlen auch die schulen teilt
ganz normaler teil des
infektionsgeschehen sind und insofern
ist es glaube ich richtig dass wir uns
jetzt entschieden haben bis mitte
februar die schulen geschlossen zu
halten
und jetzt müssen wir einfach gucken hier
werden je besser wir in die situation
kommen dass wir die infektionszahlen
runter kriegen wir haben auch und das
hat die kanzlerin ja auch schon gesagt
und darauf geeinigt dass kitas und auch
schulen priorität haben sie wieder zu
öffnen
je besser wir die zahlen runter kriegen
umso mehr können wir dort möglich machen
aber eines will ich auch sagen natürlich
sehen wir was wir unseren familien und
auch den kindern in dieser situation
zumuten aber gesundheitsschutzes etwas
was gerade ein die hohe priorität hat um
einfach die pandemie im griff zu halten
und ich sehe auch dass in den meisten
schulen dort wo es möglich ist wirklich
schon sehr pragmatisch und sehr gute
lösungen gefunden worden sind um
unterricht trotzdem weiter möglich zu
machen
ich möchte ihnen einmal zeigen was eine
schülerin uns an bild geschickt hat was
sie denkt über die situation in den
schulen in deutschland keine
videokonferenzen die kriegen nur
aufgaben die wird von bestimmten punkt
abgeben müssen ich bin der die schüler
brauchen dieses untereinander in der
schule seien die lehrer und einfach
gemeinsam wehren
wirklich wünschen werden die konferenzen
und mehr das internet nutzen
herr li na china geht das wenn sie das
hören
das hat man früher nicht gekannt nur das
kleine kinder dass jugendliche sieht
sich danach sehnen endlich wieder in die
schule zu kommen
schule ist ja nicht nur ein lernort
schule ist auch ein ort wo kinder und
jugendliche sich begegnen
die brauchen auch den umgang ich denke
ganz oft an familien die vielleicht auch
beengt leben wo die eltern gleichzeitig
noch aus dem home office arbeiten
müssten das sind ganz enorme
belastungssituationen die da entstehen
insbesondere für die mütter die oft im
haushalt die hauptlast tragen und
vielleicht jetzt nicht bei der süßen
schülerinnen die sie eingeblendet haben
aber bei vielen droht wirklich einen ein
echter bruch in der bildungsbiografie
viele werden das lernen neu lernen
müssen und jede woche die weiter
verstreicht die führt zu einem ganz
großen sozialen schaden weshalb wir
darüber nachdenken müssen wie wir auch
zeit mit innovativen methoden
präsenzunterricht wieder möglich machen
können luftreiniger gibt es es gibt
natürlich auch andere raum programme die
denkbar sind kinosäle theatersäle sind
geschlossenen hotels haben flächen die
genutzt werden können also wir müssen
schnellstmöglich öffnen und ich sehe
unter den ländern da ja auch bereits
eine intensive debatte die kolleginnen
von frau k die check in baden
württemberg beispielsweise wollte ja zum
ersten februar wieder öffnen und wurde
dann vom ministerpräsidenten wohl
eingebremst also hier zeigt sich bereits
eine erhebliche notwendigkeit in den
ländern und vor allen dingen in den
familien eher lauterbach müssen die
schulen wieder aufgemacht werden so
schnell wie möglich wir hören jetzt
dagegen dass es stimmen gewinnt
thüringen dass man bis nach ostern
warten will ist das realistisch das
hielte ich für falsch muss man klar
sagen also dass du die schule in ihr
der verlängerung und verschärfungen des
doktors zugelassen habe das war richtig
was hatten auch die erfahrungen in
england gesagt jetzt versuchen ja
derzeit also den den ausbruch von bas
ansehen insbesondere in deutschland zu
verhindern
und das ist tatsächlich in dieser phase
in der wir jetzt sind nur möglich indem
man auch die schulen geschlossen hält
und gleichzeitig das home-office massiv
stark aber danach musste es also wir
müssen wir bei andere konzepte
nachdenken
und die wäre ein vorschlag der folgende
man hat bisher die schulen relativ vater
angenommen die betriebe sind zum teil
also wenn man nicht ganz so hart daran
genommen worden
ich möchte ich möchte ich möchte ich
gern burgwächter wichtigen eigenen punkt
machen weil ich wohl einen vorschlag
machen womit wir sicherstellen kann ich
wollte wenn sie einverstanden sind der
holzhammer würde ich gerne einen
praktischen vorschlag machen wie es mit
größerer wahrscheinlichkeit gelingen
kann dass wir die schulen wieder öffnen
können und auch dauerhaft offen halten
können wir sie und wenn sie wieder zu
schaffen
mein vorschlag wäre der dass wir die
neuen selbst dass die es möglich werden
dass wir die verbindliche den betrieben
einsetzen studien zeigen ganz da will
man in den betrieben die belegschaft 200
aber mit einem antigen selbst testet
dann sind die betriebe mehr oder weniger
von kone ausbrüchen falls war und das
ist im übrigen auch die beste methode um
früherkennung von also ausbrüchen in der
bevölkerung ganz anzuerkennen wenn wir
das täten dann könnte mit einem
intelligenten schulkonzept und ich bin
ich sogar in teilen der gleichen meinung
war dass da vieles was wir machen
könnten bisher nicht ausgeschöpft worden
ist zum beispiel raumkonzepte
klosteranlage und dergleichen aber dann
können wir mit intelligenten
schulkonzerten die schulen öffnen aber
das ging ja nur wenn wir in den
betrieben besser werden und der
vorschlag die belegschaft auch kosten
malt wegen der arbeitgeber zwei mal pro
woche durch ein anti gen tests um selbst
machen zu testen da wird einem ganz ganz
großen teil der fälle
genau so die studie zum beispiel von den
biologen michael meier zeigen dass es
wahrscheinlich wenn man von impfungen
einmal absieht die technische maßnahme
wäre die also den größten unterschied
auch die begrenzung der neuen vahr
zahlen hätte ich möchte einmal mit in
die runde nehmen einen mann der sich
auskennt in dieser frage lars landowsky
alamos ski sie sie haben den in einem
hintergrund in ihrer schule
wenn sie jetzt sich das anhören was in
der politik debattiert wird dazu halten
sie es für realistisch dass die schulen
wieder geöffnet werden können finden sie
das richtig also ich muss an der stelle
erst mal meine verwunderung zum ausdruck
bringen
erst mal guten abend in die runde
darunter deshalb komme aus
rheinland-pfalz lehrergewerkschaft tätig
und es ist eben nicht so dass die
schulen bis mitte februar zu bleiben wir
starten am ersten februar mit wechsel
unterricht und die schulen in
rheinland-pfalz und ich spreche da
bestimmt auch für alle anderen und viele
bundesländer sind überhaupt nicht
hinreichend was den gesundheitsschutz
angeht vorbereitung das nach zehn
monaten pardini stellt das einen das
davor große fragen wir haben hier in
rheinland pfalz weder hinreichend fb2
masken zur verfügung noch raumluft
filteranlagen noch hat man eine corona
test strategie die in irgendeiner art
und weise hinreichen und ausreichend ist
und das nach zehn monaten ich weiß nicht
was da verschlafen wurde
wo da die probleme liegen aber hier muss
grundlegend etwas passiert ich bin vom
herzen grundschulpädagogen und ich
möchte dass die kinder möglichst schnell
wieder in der schule sind
fernunterricht kann präsenzunterricht
überhaupt nicht ersetzen das ist ganz
klar
aber ich kann doch in zeiten wie jetzt
wo wir sagen es darf nur eine person von
außen in die indians privathaus kommen
und die frau kanzlerin hat ja auch noch
gesagt na ja bitte auch die zahl
begrenzen was er vernünftig ist und hole
dann ab erster februar einer teils 15
haushalte in einen raum also das kann
also in einen klassenraum das kann doch
wohl wirklich nicht der ernst sein
und das bei völlig
unzureichende gesundheitsschutz
maßnahmen hier muss nachgelegt werden
und man sollte die kette schulen
wirklich konsequent bis mindestens mitte
februar zu lassen den gesundheitsschutz
hochfahren und selber den hochgefahren
hat dann kann man die schuhe auch wieder
völlig mit gutem gewissen auch wieder
öffnen aber genau das was der
lauterbacher grad gesagt hat diesen test
strategie fehlt hinten und vorne
wir brauchen tests wir brauchen erst
freimachten zwei pro tag pro
arbeitskraft in der schule und ich meine
pro arbeitskraft da kann auch nicht
wieder hin und her gehen na ja der ist
angestellte beim schulträger der ist
beim land angestellt der ist daran
gestellt nein alle die schule arbeitet
brauchen diesen arbeitsschutz braucht
dann direkt infrage weitergeleitet dann
von khalid sheikh von conject wenn sie
das hören der verzweifelt man doch oder
ich meine dass das hört sich doch
umsetzbaren besorgen sie tests geben sie
uns personal masken und dann schaffen
wir das dann packen wir das an wieso
bauen sie dann nicht mal auf den tisch
und rufen auch die bildungsminister aus
allen ländern zusammen und sagen wir
brauchen jetzt hier endlich eine
strategie also erst mal haben sich die
bundesländer auf eine strategie
grundsätzlich geeinigt dass sie eine
hohe priorität den abschlussklassen
einräumen dass die abschlussklassen
möglichst durchgehend und daneben auch
mit abstand und hygiene konzepten
unterricht geben unterricht bekommen und
das eben auch unterricht vor ort
durchgeführt wird die zweite stufe ist
dass man eben sagt die zweite priorität
räumt man dann eben den grundschülern
einen damit auch die grundschüler dann
wieder unterricht haben können
wichtig ist doch dass wir unterschiede
zu lassen und das wir restriktiv daran
gehen so haben wir es ja auch im rahmen
der der ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin vereinbart dass wir sehr
klar gesagt haben wir wollen jetzt bis
15 februar sehr restriktive maßnahmen
durchführen und sehr restriktiv daran
gehen indem wir eben sagen wo es wo es
in irgendeiner form möglich ist sollen
die schule nehmen auch bis mitte februar
geschlossen bleiben
und mitte februar nach 5 millionen
schüler bekommen das ist unrealistisch
und das sollten wir eben auch das
sollten wir eben auch nicht in aussicht
stellen weil diese umsetzung wird am
ende nicht funktionieren
wichtig ist doch dass wir uns jetzt
konzepte über
und dann eben auch unterschiede möglich
machen und dann ganz klar uns auch an
den an den infektionszahlen orientieren
da wo die infektionszahlen sehr weit
runter gehen kann man natürlich einen
anderen unterricht möglich machen
vielleicht dann eben doch mit einer mit
einer test strategie die dann vielleicht
nicht ganz so häufig ist wie sie es
fordern denn das wird in der tat nicht
umsetzbar sein alamos kia sie ihre idee
ist unrealistisch sagt die ministerin
weil es eben um elf millionen schüler
geht was ist ihre entgegnung ich glaube
nicht dass es unrealistisch ist also wir
haben geld in deutschland wie man den
letzten monaten gesehen haben wir haben
die mehrwertsteuer mal eben auf 16%
runtergedrückt ich glaube das geld hätte
man besser angelegt um raumluft
filteranlagen in den schulen einzusetzen
die zwei masten entschuldigung ja also
wir sprechen von arbeitsschutz an der
stelle und da muss man nachlegen und es
kann nicht sein also 300 haben wir ja
noch dicker bekommen wir haben zwei
lieferung bekommen das gericht kam wir
nachher die nachricht diese bitte zu
entsorgen weil die nicht hinreichend vor
corona schützen und bis heute haben wir
nur erste hilfe masken also nur fit in
erster hilfe einsatz das darf nicht sein
und wir brauchen wenn die schon
aufgemacht wurden herr lauterbach
vielleicht bestätigen sie dass wir
brauchen den angemessen
gesundheitsschutz und dann beruhigt
öffnen zu können und ich wiederhole wir
wollen öffnen wir sind
grundschulpädagogen wir wollen dass die
kinder kommen
aber bitte mit einem entsprechenden
gesundheitsschutz und was den
fernunterricht angeht auch noch dazu
etwas das kind es tut mir leid dass das
kind da so eine sage ich mal nicht
gerade vorbildlicher art und weise des
fernunterrichts haben ich erlebe das
aber auch an vielen stellen ganz anders
das läuft relativ gut er setzt natürlich
nicht an präsenzunterricht das ist ganz
klar
aber wenn ich mein kollegium sehe das
macht mehrere videokonferenzen pro tag
und das auf einer völlig unzureichenden
grundlage nämlich nicht immer
funktionierenden videokonferenzen deren
plattform ist da kann man vielleicht
später noch zu kommen lamont ski ganz
kurz ich möchte herrn lauterbach ganz
kurz verabschieden aus der runde der
noch einen weiteren termin hat er laut
aber herzlichen dank möchte noch für
eine kurze weitere diskussion frau kunze
mit rein nehmen sie
dieses bekannte schauspielerin lebt in
köln und hat mit ihrem mann drei kinder
im alter von 10 13 und 17 und quält sich
wie viele eltern durch homeschooling und
distanz unterricht vor kunze wie erleben
sie die situation in der pandemie als
mutter wie gut funktioniert bei ihnen
zuhause homeschooling abend erstmal und
vielen dank dass ich bei der diskussion
dabei sein darf ich glaube es geht uns
wie den meisten anderen familien es ist
sehr sehr schwierig und ich habe das
gefühl dass die kinder und wir leider
sehr oft allein gelassen sind und ich
stelle mir wirklich auch die frage was
ist in diesen neun monaten passiert also
beim lockdown eins war klar das ist für
alle das erstemal eine ausnahme
situation aber neun monate später
lockdown 2 es ist nicht wirklich was
passiert und frau kann ich sie haben das
eben gesagt man liegt das hauptaugenmerk
auf die abschlussklassen also ich habe
eine 17 jährige tochter die jetzt abitur
machen darf und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
diese schüler fühlen sich so was von
alleine gelassen und nicht genug
vorbereitet und die sind alle sehr aktiv
die wollen und die geben auch alles aber
da wird viel zu wenig getan und es tut
dann auch sehr weh wenn man von
politikansätze wird wie warum soll man
den kindern das war einfach in die haben
genug zeit zu lernen und auch karneval
fällt weg die können herz karnevalstagen
auch zum lernen nehmen glauben sie mir
die kinder lernen wie verrückt ich würde
mich fast aus dem fenster lehnen und
sagen die lernen mehr als zu normalen
schulzeiten und es ist für alle sehr
schwierig und sie wissen auch dass
gerade die seelischen verhältnisse bei
den kindern ja da sieht es eigentlich
auch gerade nicht sehr gut aus die
kinder vereinsamen die sozialen kontakte
fallen komplett weg
es ist ein wunder ball der nicht gut
läuft und im moment sind wir alle glaube
ich ziemlich am ende
und für uns alle sehr allein gelassen
und sagt sie fühlt sich am ende die
kinder tun viel aber man fühlt nicht
genügend unterstützung von der politik
warum sagen sie nicht wir machen da
jetzt mehr
müssen mehr machen weil eben die schulen
länger dicht bleiben also zum einen
möchte ich einmal sagen ich kann diese
situation in der die jungen leute sind
sehr sehr gut nachvollziehen und ich
verstehe auch dass das eine sehr
belastende situation ist also ich hab
auch genau die sind zwar schon aus der
schule aber es ist noch nicht so lange
her und ich glaube wir sehen in diesen
tagen alle dass auch diese gefühlslage
dass wir das im moment alle als sehr
belastend empfinden egal in welchem
bereich wird tätig sind oder eben auch
vielleicht gerade nicht tätig sind auch
kann ich länger aber verstehen alleine
verstehen alleine hilft ja dann nicht
sondern so aber auch maßnahmen so und
dann ja aber dann muss man aber dann
muss man sich überlegen was ist was ist
denn die lösung wir müssen eben auch
aufpassen dass dieser jahrgang jetzt ein
vollwertiges abitur machen kann man muss
sich im die kultusminister der länder
sind in diesen tagen in der diskussion
wie sie jetzt mit den abschlüssen
vernünftig umgehen
am ende ist es aber nicht nur eine frage
des abschlusses am ende ist es eine
frage dessen ob wir den kindern für ihr
leben genügend beibringen und wenn heute
etwas wegfällt was sie aufgrund der
situation nicht wehren können dann
sollen wir doch darüber nachdenken wie
kann man ihnen das ermöglichen dass sie
das entweder nachholen können oder
gerade auch für die leistungsschwächeren
dass wir uns für die überlegen was wir
dafür angebote machen können um nachhol
möglichkeiten zu schaffen hinsicht zu
reden ist wichtig dafür über die inhalte
reden gehen sie davon aus dass ihre
tochter ein normales abitur machen wird
ja ich gehe davon aus die ist auch sehr
bemüht aber genau das würde ich gerne
noch mal in die runde werfen und ich
weiß es ist nicht das erste mal gesagt
worden aber ich höre sehr viel die ganze
zeit wir müssen jetzt überlegen und das
ist ja mal einen vorwurf wenn ich das so
wenn ich das so sagen darf was ist denn
neun monaten passiert wir waren uns doch
alle im klaren darüber und das muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen dass ein zweiter
locker und sehr wahrscheinlich ist und
auf und jeder konzept technisch das kann
ich nur unterschreiben was der kollege
auch eben gesagt hat es ist an den
schulen nichts passiert
wir können doch nicht jetzt sagen ja das
neue virus das mutierte greift auch
schlimmer kinder und jugendliche an
aber wir müssen zurück zum
präsenzunterricht aber es ist nichts
passiert die gene konzepte funktionieren
nicht die lehrer können das nicht
umsetzen
wie soll ich dann als mutter meine
kinder da überhaupt überlegen in die
schule zu schicken und nein ich finde
nicht dass da irgendwas passiert ist und
ich kann es ihnen nur sagen und das sind
auch die worte der kinder
keiner wird uns wirklich zu keiner den
neun monaten wirklich reagiert und für
uns etwas getan und wie sollen wir jetzt
damit weitergeht ich glaube dass viele
kinder ihren abschluss machen und die
werden denen auch gut machen
ich bin erstaunt und angetan was unsere
kinder und jugendlichen gerade leisten
ich verneige mich vor den aber wir
brauchen hier hilfe für die kinder wir
müssen die kinder auffangen das ist
unsere zukunft und das ist unsere
verdammte pflicht und schuldigkeit da
ist neun monaten viel zu wenig passiert
viel zu wenig herr lindner unsere
verdammte pflicht und schuldigkeit auch
die fdp sitzt in einigen regierungen
unter anderem rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen
was können sie jetzt in dieser lage mehr
tun auch wenn man hört dass eben diese
pandemie noch viel länger dauern könnte
weil wir einfach zu wenig impfstoff
haben also mit blick auf
nordrhein-westfalen sehe ich dass dort
für den distanz unterricht zumindest so
viele mittel bereitgestellt worden sind
wie nirgendwo sonst im bundesgebiet alle
bedürftigen schülerinnen und schüler
erhalten jetzt ein digitales endgerät
auch die lehrerinnen und lehrer erhalten
ein solches also das was möglich ist
wird getan mit blick auf die
digitalisierung haben wir es allerdings
mit einem aufholprozess zu tun weil wir
ja jahre wenn nicht jahrzehnte verloren
haben ich glaube dass die situation an
den schuh an den kitas und den schuhen
aber symptomatisch ist für das ganze
land man könnte ähnliches sagen über
sporteinrichtungen kultur und anderes
mehr
wir konzentrieren uns darauf schon seit
einigen monaten immer weiter zu
schließen und wir müssen jetzt den
umstieg schaffen durch ffp zwei masken
durch test strategien durch luftreiniger
durch ein regional differenziertes
vorgehen und vielleicht auch dass man
lehrerinnen und lehrern den
erzieherinnen und erziehern schneller
ein impfangebot macht weil sie auch sehr
systemrelevant sind ähnlich wie
pflegekräfte im bereich der medizin oder
ärztinnen und ärzte
auch sollte man dort überlegen bei der
priorisierung dort nochmal zu justieren
weil kitas und schule das ist die
sensibelste stelle gewissermaßen einen
dominostein wenn kitas und schulen
fallen in dem sinne dass sich schließen
müssen
dann haben wir die auswirkungen in der
ganzen gesellschaft weil die eltern
belastet sind weil dann betriebe nicht
arbeiten können also müssen wir alle
anstrengungen darauf konzentrieren kitas
und schulen so schnell wie möglich zu
öffnen und offen zu halten
distanz unterricht jedenfalls und
digitale didaktik ersetzen den normalen
schulunterricht das miteinander nicht
wie lange wie lange alles dauert so
zusagen in der bildungspolitik möchte
ich ihnen einmal mit einem zitat zeigen
und übergab bullmann der
wissenschaftsministerin aus 2001 war das
ein laptop pro schüler ist das ziel das
war am 4
april 2001 bodycheck davon kann man auch
heute noch jahre später nur träumen
ich glaube wir hätten uns alle
miteinander gewünscht dass wir in der
digitalisierung weiter gewesen wären
wenn man so eine pandemie bekommen sehen
wir haben über den digital packt ja seit
vielen jahren diskutiert wir haben ihnen
2019 zusammen quasi vereinbart und von
da an konnte die umsetzung laufen aber
so ehrlich sollten wir sein dass diese
umsetzung eben auch vielleicht nicht so
schnell vonstatten gegangen ist wie sie
wie wir uns das alle miteinander
gewünscht hätten
jetzt sind wir in der situation dass wir
über den sommer und deswegen frau kunst
dass gar nichts passiert ist das kann
ich an dieser stelle auch nur
zurückweisen wir haben über den sommer
relativ schnell die weitere förderung
für die endgeräte der jungen leute die
noch nicht versorgt waren auf den weg
gebracht wir haben die vereinbarung mit
den ländern
gemacht dass auch die administratoren
systeme professionalisiert werden und
wir haben die vereinbarung mit den
lehrer laptops auf den weg gebracht um
eben für eine vollumfängliche
ausstattung zu sorgen
aber das ist natürlich in einer pandemie
schwierig diese ganze technische
ausstattung umzusetzen weil an manchen
schulen fehlt es einfach auch nur
überhaupt an anbindung an
breitbandanbindungen und an dieser
stelle ist das natürlich auch nicht
einfach jetzt in der pandemie mal eben
so nachzuholen deswegen wird es auch so
sein dass im laufe der pandemie die
unterschiede eher größer geworden sind
weil gerade da wo man schon technisch
sehr weiterer hatte man natürlich auch
jetzt die möglichkeit daran weiter zu
khalid sheikh wir wollen ganz konkret
bleiben hierbei die richtigen fragen
deshalb frau bulmahn hat gesagt 2001 ein
laptop pro schüler ist das ziel
wann hat jeder schüler deutschland ein
laptop also über unsere für über unsere
fördervereinbarung dass jetzt die jungen
leute ausgestattet werden die vorher
nicht ausgestattet werden und über die
schulen einen leih lernten einen laptop
bekommen müsst ihr jetzt im grunde jeder
schüler ausgestattet sein so ist die
vereinbarung kann ich da mal auch
dazulernen denn das ja bitte wer denn
jetzt heller muss ja also ich möchte
ganz dringend da in berlin wir brauchen
eigentlich endlich einen masterplan für
deutschland für die schulen in
deutschland und zwar heißt das was sind
die mindest an das eines klassenraumes
an digitalisierung und nicht jedes
bundesland jeder schulträger geht
alleine auf die reise das ist einfach
nur peinlich was hier veranstaltet wird
wir brauchen einen raus nur ja und nein
und was ist damals zeigen ob man sagen
ja einfach ein punkt noch diese diene
dieser digital takter ist kommt sie
gerade auf einen an eine sache die mir
ganz wichtig ist ich verstehe es nicht
ich habe im märz april im
bildungsausschuss in rheinland pfalz im
landtag habe ich gesagt schaffen sie die
konzepte ab für die schuhträger die die
schreiben müssen und für die schulen
deshalb mehrere wochen gedauert bis die
frau hob ich dass man oben weitergegeben
hat und das mal umgesetzt worden ist als
gab gehabt asiatin sihe wir müssen
endlich und zwar nachhaltig ein
masterplan für die digitalisierung ja
schon
nun haben das geht ganz schnell
digitalisierung mahnt mindeststandards
für einen klassenraum und dann von oben
dirigiert und nicht etwa alles ausländer
und schulträger verteilt das war
komplett for kunst
die ministerin hat gesagt dass
eigentlich jeder zumindest ein laptop
haben müsste trifft das super ihren
kindern also war und seinen kindern
trifft das zu werden uns aber auch
selber darum gekümmert haben ich kenne
viele familien der kinder nicht alle
einen eigenen laptop haben und vor allem
möchte ich auch noch zu bedenken geben
allein aktobe ist schön und gut aber wer
holt die kinder nennen die kinder haben
doch oft gar keine ahnung und wir haben
auch familien mit migrationshintergrund
die eltern können gar nicht aufgrund von
sprachbarrieren ihren kindern dieses
gerät erklären wir brauchen doch auch
leute wie die kinder damit eben da
unterrichten wie gehe ich mit dem laptop
um wie mache ich das wir sehen das doch
auch jetzt in den zoom meetings oder den
team meetings da fliegen ein kind nach
man dann raus dann versuchen die wieder
reinzukommen das alles stört wieder
diesen unterricht der für die lehrer
sicher auch nicht einfach ist also es
gibt so viele schrauben an denen wir
drehen müssen und die vielleicht auch
nicht bedacht werden und ich sehe ihre
bemühungen aber wir brauchen einfach
taten wenn wir immer zu überlegen was
können wir verbessern
es muss was passieren und vielleicht
wäre es auch ein weg und ich weiß dass
sie oder ich kann ja an wievielen sie
alle um die ohren amt was das auch für
sie für die situation ist aber
vielleicht brauchen wir auch leute die
an die schulen gehen im gespräch mit den
lehrern und den schülern sind und im
schul bezogen auch arbeiten das ist
nicht jedes konzept für jede schule
gleich besetzt war
und das dürfen sie nicht außer acht
lassen herzlichen dank für kunst das
nehmen wir auf jeden fall mit jetzt in
einer ganz schnellen abschlussrunde frau
carlitscheck und herr lindner thema des
tages heute neben corona oder im
zusammenhang mit corona bodo ramelow der
jetzt auch wieder dpa gestanden hat dass
er bei den mpk es ab und summer kenitra
spielt vor carlitscheck wie geht ihnen
das in den sitzungen die sie haben wie
lenken sie sich ab
zu viel haben vielleicht auch hierbei
die richtigen fragen wenn sie mal denken
sie müssen sich ein bisschen ablenken
naja wir müssen uns ja nicht ablenken
wir sollten einander gut zuhören damit
für vernünftige lösungen finden in
dieser schwierigen situation und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn man den
diskussionen mal sehr gut zuhört dann
hört man auch warum es unterschiede in
deutschland geben muss und das ist
wichtig weil die situation
unterschiedlich ist in den bundesländern
und auch in den bundesländern ganz
unterschiedliche strukturen da sind das
gilt gerade auch im bildungsbereich da
sind gewachsene strukturen da die die
die sehr akzeptiert sind vor ort und
deswegen kann man nicht sagen wir machen
eine lösung für alle und das kann man
gerade auch bei diesen intensiven
diskussionen zwischen den
ministerpräsident und der
bundeskanzlerin lernen aber meine frage
was spielen sie aber kann die crash oder
schach oder backgammon auf ihrem handy
nebenbei wenn es zu lange dauert in den
amerikas oder den videokonferenzen
also ich habe meistens unterlagen dabei
wenn ich gerade nicht gefordert bin kann
ich in meinen unterlagen arbeiten
herr lindner wie lenken sie sich ab wenn
sie mal gar keinen bock haben wir
zuzuhören
dann schaue ich dass die sitzungen
beschleunigt wird weil wir alles in
dieser pandemie alle in der pandemie
viel zu tun haben und ich bin nicht sehr
glücklich mit dieser diskussion um herrn
angelogen möchte mich deshalb an dieser
debatte auch gar nicht so sehr
beteiligen einsatz zur frau carlitscheck
ich bin anderer meinung ich glaube wir
müssen in unseren bildungsföderalismus
zwischen 16 ländern zu mehr
vergleichbarkeit kommen und zugleich
müssen bestimmte bürokratische
förderrichtlinien wie etwa beim digital
packt massiv verschlankt werden
die schule hat was damit zu tun sich um
die kinder und jugendlichen zu kümmern
die können jetzt für für
bewilligungsbescheide nicht noch
umfänglicher anträge verfassen
ich glaube da können wir besser und
schneller werden frau kunze und herr
lammers ski auch an sie die letzte frage
womit lenken sie sich in diesen schweren
zeiten ab gibt es irgendeinen geheim
trick den sie vielleicht auch den eltern
mit auf den weg geben können vor kunst
und wir versuchen natürlich hier schöne
momente zu schaffen
wir gehen in die freie natur und wir
versuchen hier zu hause mit spielen mit
spielenachmittag mit backen mit kochen
und auch mal mit einem filmnachmittag
einfach wenn wir dann die zeit haben
neben imhof school in schöne momente zu
schaffen und ich glaube das ist das
allerwichtigste
was wir gerade unseren kindern jetzt
schuldig sind wir müssen tolle momente
schaffen und ja momente an die sie
vielleicht auch gerne zurückdenken wenn
sie an diesem ski was man ihr tollster
moment als pädagoge im pandemie ja gab
es da ein
also ich sage jetzt eins das da gibt es
kaum ein wann ich hoffe dass endlich
etwas passiert für die schulen vor ort
und wir müssen hier wie ich habe gar
keine zeit da führen wir über solche
sachen gedanken zu machen
ich bin als gewerkschafter unterwegs und
versucht seit monaten hier ein bisschen
tempo rein zu bringen
die ganze angelegenheit ist gelegt mir
leider nicht und oder nur sag ich mal
sehr sehr wenig und von daher ich
wünsche mir dass und das meine ich eben
mit candy krass spielen bei der mpk
sitzung ja also ich wünsche mir dass das
können sie gerne machen machen sie das
weiter aber bitte 1 wenn die beschlüsse
da sind die man auf höchster
demokratischer ebene fast zwischen
ministerpräsidenten und kanzlerin dann
sollte es möglich sein dass die auch
durchgesetzt werden und unten
durchgeführt werden
und ich lebe in einem bundesland wo
diese vereinbarung hintergangen wird
indem man die schulen doch wieder öffnet
und das bein vorzeitig habe es eben
gehört impfen wird schwierig mutiertes
virus ist da und dann schicke ich die
kinder wieder beim alten
gesundheitsschutz in die schule
das kann beim besten willen nicht sein
das kann nicht der ernst sein und hier
muss nachgelegt werden und zwar nicht
noch durch reden sondern zügig und jetzt
geht s los förderprogramm für diese
warmluft filteranlagen und zwar schnell
die masken müssen her und zwar zügig wie
er mit recht wir müssen an diese
thematik mit dem impfen rand da kommen
wir überhaupt gar nicht drum rum und das
war ein schöner bürgeln hella moskau sie
haben vollkommen recht was das tempo
angeht sowohl in der bildung als auch
beim impfen das waren die zwei
wichtigsten themen dieser woche die wir
bei die richtigen fragen heute
diskutiert haben
und der eine hinweis sondern auch seine
frau kunst er hat von schönen momenten
gesprochen und morgen hat sie so einen
nimmt einen podcast mit ihrer tochter
auf aus zu dieser situation der sei zu
empfehlen
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
sonntagabend und ich wünsche uns allen
dass diese probleme angepackt werden
dass wir in deutschland endlich mehr
impfstoff haben dass es den menschen die
jetzt leiden besser geht und dass wir
auch in der bildung vorankommen
herzlichen dank das war die richtigen
fragen bis morgen
[Musik]